welcome to Burger Time burger don't just
make burgers come we have to make enough
maybe a vote no okay fine
why did you go okay before we serve the
burger we got to wash it make sure it's
good uh what are you doing tricky I
figured maybe she doesn't want to eat it
because I don't have a tray on the
burger oh yeah plates or grates plates
are great sin dates well [ __ ] we got
mixed we need your help here Oh God the
burger is escaping
I'm sorry Yelp's all right I don't know
what's even going on Oh Jay I need your
help with it oh god the burger
disappeared in the floor oh my god I've
so much lag right now wait what did you
do every time I try teaches you all
these burgers are burnt they look like
hockey pucks I'm making the burger on
the left
Jason so many rats oh you can't pick
them out can we fry them mmm yeah fried
rats delicious you turn my burger
upside-down you're welcome
thank you any time thanks uh okay [ __ ]
better eat her burger she does not eat
the burger hey what did you put it on a
tray oh you did I did you ever slap yes
Oh what happened oh I guess you're not
allowed to slap uh I don't really know
what he's like how are we ever gonna
make anything he's poking me stop the
restaurant what does he want
he keeps pointing at me I'm gonna have
to get a [ __ ] nose stop pointing at
me ah brother max what is he doing what
does he want
Tom knows he knows it's you I think so
alright let's order stuff nobody just
slapping the [ __ ] out of the scream
that's me you asked me I'm making orders
I'm making order this is different well
how do I kill the rat wrap it right away
put them in the wash oh oh you have to
drain him I'm punching the rat guys a
few times you get okay well I gave a guy
got it I got it
okay um wasn't there a burger but he's
gonna like it anyway let's wash it in
the water to make sure
get the bath so it's not and dirty right
we're here's my broker all right they're
clean exactly until moving I think this
is a good a good little restroom we're
running it oh yeah Aaron is so clean
even we wash the racket down the red
stop moving I don't understand what
happened
did you ground it and my burger is
bouncing in me right the red is ready to
be cooked oh it's still alive no it is
pretending to be dead keep grounding it
keep drowning it okay I'm drowning for
real this time I'm supervising you
drowning it piers okay okay you are
gonna hate you guys Peter is loving this
you guys should be happy that we wash
our rats and keep the hygiene yeah we're
like helping the rats man okay I think
it's that now the right how do I pick
things up I'm fregley get this [ __ ]
[ __ ] rats why would you get drainie
oh you have to put them in the fry sauce
maybe maybe that's it I do die then
rusty friend rats are running away come
back here right okay [ __ ] look at me oh
this guy's try and really hard to make a
burger and I'm putting the rat on top of
it oh no it's still alive goddamn it I
got it I got it I got it
let's put it on the burger too many
people try to grab the rat and that runs
away okay I have it on the burger abuts
in cardboard he wants a cup anything
else at the rat-free now have had a
bacon micro burger and he runs back in
the restaurant son of a [ __ ] haircut
where'd you get your haircut
I want that haircut stop he's erasing
passes by I got the burger and I got the
bacon bacon in his face he he won't tell
me where he got his hair cut styles
rights if woman that's why you're
opening oh I'll make a choke on the
bacon come here but at least you got
sweet curves she has very nice curves
I'm gonna make a choke on the bacon dude
now don't you wish him and put here we
go there we go not here there we go
reason yes eat something yeah
welcome to Burger tower [ __ ] Joe
don't let him escape
I'm holding him grab his ear I think I
gotta put a burger on the doorway so he
can't walk out past it sir stay say hey
so look at the rope
okay get my hand fire up I'm gonna get
I'm gonna get him some lettuce and he'll
taste that and want to stay forever okay
no let's get the bacon
now this is not harassment if you like
it give me that black I got their twins
twenties we we just reunited to twit
long yes every roll back hand okay the
bag I need a broke leg it I think I hit
it
hey [ __ ] let's get him in the
kitchen and fries ass or making through
the dishes or surprise you got my
civilian oh my god when did he go
oblivion he became our counter look even
the rats are leaving our kitchen even
the rats are like no I mean [ __ ] this
[ __ ] name I ain't havin any of this [ __ ]
I didn't become a rat to get I can smell
someone's ruckus here
oh it's here it the orders come in ain't
no don't you make sure you're holding
the pickup idea where you get to the
boxes thank you otherwise they're gonna
explode okay okay I was a truck doing
well they see it's a drug to do a
walk-through yeah and all the rats are
coming now - yeah me like truck that is
definitely scary just should provide
some smooth criminal' while the trucks
backing out
since smooth don't defecate it out
better than dead and then just moon
walks way out of scream nice he's [ __ ]
you [ __ ] leech people just left why
are you leaving why are they leaving
what's wrong with our food hey not me
I'm coming with samples I'll make sure
they taste them okay this guy here this
is our next victim okay this this this
guy here mmm bacon you like the bacon
don't you you like a tomato in tomatoes
wait the what did I just say okay pewds
I've got a burger they can eat the
burger at the frozen burger and then
they're gonna be happy okay okay nice
flags you see overlord Keller would get
the rash bring essica tickler bomb quick
through the demon race y'all wait
Parcher give her like give her like the
Nazi salute now don't you that someone
already made that joke before really
yeah I'm done that's it she's purged no
I think ya can tell by her face sook
unit let her go let her go let's see
what happened tell my own facial
expression just tell cry you found the
perfect woman for her for him frak [ __ ]
I ship right cry and my lady
team is randomized what should we call
them hash tagging cragger Kirk recruit
Kruger oh my god all this stuff in the
sink we got to make sure it's clean in
hygiene and [ __ ] guard up the box oh
yeah I'm sorry box bus trying to break 3
oh god oh god is taking over the kitchen
trash oh I have a new bucks to fight the
other box you gotta flail your arms is
she running he's just running away
somebody's in the kitchen going [ __ ]
batshit yeah oh god he's stuck that's
what I have his arm is stuck I don't
want to keep going in there anymore he
blocked this off it's like a move on
I'll save you you guys run away ways on
the street everybody play what happens
if we escape this world that in the van
oh that's a good idea and no don't let
it leave it up me okay get it attendant
oh hey so like through Sally's butt